Now that you've learned the basics about drawing texts let's combine it all and
make a simple mean generator.
We've given you a head start with some basic HTML.
Inside this HTML, you'll find a few things but
let me point out what's important.
Here in this section of HTML we're creating the top line and
bottom line entries, which you can see right here.
This is where a user will be able to type in text that they want to
appear on the image.
Inside the script tag,
we'll find all the necessary components to start building the meme generator.
We can see here, in this if statement, we're getting the text that was made in
the top and bottom lines, and then we have this function called
redraw meme where we get the canvas and select the context like we did before.
After that we can see a place where your code goes.
Then we've got this save file function which is going to let us use
the toDataURL method to hopefully save our images.
Then we've got this handleFileSelect method which will help us load a file from
the disk as an image for the background.
But the most important thing is that your code goes within this redraw
mean function.
So put together everything that you've learned so far.
Use the background image and
put some text over it to create this meme generator.
So, now that you've got the starter code for a simple meme maker,
can you use the canvas to load images with that iconic meme text?
When you're done, check this box to continue.